so today I want to have a slightly
different conversation related to
impeachment which i think is an
important one and it's actually one that
may at least open the door to achieving
something politically rather than
focusing on the removal of President
Trump and what I mean by this is that
when the topic of impeachment for Donald
Trump comes up 99% of the time it's
someone talking about obstruction of
justice or witness tampering basically
related directly or indirectly to the
Moller probe and I believe that there is
a completely reasonable case to be made
for impeachment over obstruction but as
I've said before it's just not gonna
happen in the sense that Republicans
aren't going to go for it it will be
framed by Republicans as a partisan act
by Democrats to try to impeach Donald
Donald Trump over obstruction it may
still achieve a 20/20 strategic goal but
in terms of achieving an immediate
political sort of change it's just not
going to happen so my suggestion today
is let's put that aside for a second
okay let's completely forget about
obstruction and impeachment because you
don't actually need obstruction to
justify impeachment proceedings against
Donald Trump this is barely being talked
about but there are a couple of articles
about the descriptions
this YouTube clip but looking only at
Donald Trump's actions in Yemen and
arguably looking at Donald Trump's
violations of the emoluments clause you
would have a hundred and ten percent
justification for the impeachment of the
President of the United States let's go
through each of them one by one and
remember none of this has anything to do
with obstruction none of this has
anything to do with the Moller report
none of this has anything to do with
collusion or conspiracy to collude with
Russia Donald Trump's support for the
saudi-led attacks on Yemen are arguably
an impeachable offense okay
the Senate has already passed a War
Powers Resolution which is meant to stop
American military support for the Saudi
attack on Yemen that has been going on
Donald Trump has said he would veto that
Trump will prevent us from saying hold
on a second we're not gonna fund this
immoral and unconscionable war on Yemen
by Saudi Arabia any more Trump says he
would prevent us from no longer funding
that now there are other things that
Congress could do when it comes to Yemen
Congress could override Trump's veto of
that War Powers Resolution not clear
that they actually have the numbers to
do that in the political will to do that
but there is the possibility of Congress
cutting the money that is used for
supporting these attacks Trump can
authorize it Trump can say he wants to
do it he can he can veto the War Powers
Resolution but Congress still could stop
the flow of the money itself as is
Congress's constitutionally established
duty but there is a very strong case for
impeachment of Donald Trump over this
now you might say wait a second David
you just said Senate Republicans aren't
going to vote to remove Trump if he's
impeached by the house and that's true
but remember to start impeachment
proceedings you don't need two-thirds of
the Senate you only need 50% plus one in
the house which Democrats have if
Democrats impeach over obstruction that
will trigger one type of reaction from
Trump and he will buckle down it'll be
super partisan Republicans are going to
have Trump's back if Democrats instead
start impeachment or even threatened to
start impeachment over what is arguably
military and financial support of
unconstitutional participation in the
Saudi war on Yemen it's going to be less
partisan I'm not saying it won't be
partisan but there are already some
Republicans who want to end American
support of the Saudi war on Yemen and it
might even pull some of the prominent
House Democrats that opposed impeachment
like Nancy Pelosi over to our side and
the thing is it's not about removing
Trump it might actually get Trump to
stop supporting Saudis war on Yemen it
would actually do something at least
potentially the possibility of possible
impeachment over Yemen might even get
Trump to stop support by the US military
of Saudi Arabia in Yemen without needing
impeachment in and of itself to even get
going in earnest and then lastly totally
separately there's a case to be made
that Donald Trump has violated the
emoluments clause in multiple ways
receiving things of value from foreign
nations including endless hotel revenue
from foreign leaders and diplomats who
say we're staying at Trump's hotel in
Washington DC specifically to curry
favor with them to ingratiate ourselves
with Donald Trump - maybe achieve some
kind of favorable position from Donald
Trump directly or from his
administration or his Justice Department
or Commerce Department or whoever else
it is you could make the argument on
emoluments for impeachment but again
this would be specifically because of
Yemen less political than obstruction
100 percent legally warranted and I
think it is a serious debate that within
the Democratic establishment has to
happen I believe that the threat of
impeachment immediately via impeachment
hearings in the house over Yemen could
actually get Donald Trump to change his
policy on that issue and it would
directly help the people people of Yemen
obstruction impeachment you're gonna get
the immediate buckle down the witch hunt
stuff you're gonna get a very very
different
action over Yemen if Donald Trump sees
that simply stopping our support of the
Saudi war there might make that threat
of impeachment go away it's actually
possible possible that he would go
forward and do that today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom /
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blink Asst it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a 15 minute audio book you get
all the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n